When we reflected this function in the x axis, we ended up with a new equation,
this one. So we can see that all that we did was replace the square root of x
by negative square root x. Now in terms of functions, if we said that our
original equation was y equals f of x, then what we see with our reflection in
the x axis is y equals negative f of x. Reflection in the X axis just involves
negating the entire function that we're working with. But what about reflection
in the y-axis, we've seen one example of a graph showing that before, but what
happens with the equation? Well, going back to our three simple points that we
saw before, where did they end up if we reflected them in the y-axis? Please
fill in the coordinates of the new reflected points here